Hello. This is Six Minute
English from BBC Learning English
I'm Beth
and I am Neil.
Now, depending on how you look at it,
Roy Sullivan was either the luckiest
or the unluckiest man alive.
Working as a US park ranger, Roy
was struck by lightning
on seven different occasions
and survived them all.
But Roy isn't the only victim
of an unpredictable natural event,
sometimes called an act of God.
In the last decade
an estimated half a million people
have died globally
in natural disasters such as earthquakes,
tsunamis, hurricanes and cyclones.
In 2023 at least sixty thousand people died
after earthquakes in Turkey and Syria
and things are predicted to get worse
in the future due to climate change
and increasing populations.
So can anything be done to stop
natural disasters or like Roy Sullivan
should we accept that some things are
beyond our control? In this programme,
we'll be finding out and, as usual,
we will be learning
some useful new vocabulary, too.
Throughout history,
floods, when there's too much water,
and droughts, when there isn't enough,
have caused most human deaths,
but with climate change, new dangers
are emerging. But do you know
Neil, which natural disaster is
most responsible for human deaths?
Now,
um,
I'm not sure
but you do hear a lot
about terrible earthquakes
in the news, don't you?
Yeah, probably earthquakes.
Now, in her job as professor of hazard
and risk at Durham University,
Lucy Easthope
attends conferences to advise
on planning for natural emergencies.
But according to Lucy, describing
disasters as natural is a mistake,
as she told BBC Radio Four
programme Inside Science.
Probably the worst thing you can do
at a disaster conference
is describe it as a natural disaster
because that's the hopelessness
right there. The 'natural' implies
a sense of fatalism and a sense of
'let's give up now',
whereas in fact, these events...
there's huge elements that we have
in our grasp to both prevent,
and more importantly
perhaps, prevent additional harm.
Professor Easthope thinks calling
disasters, 'natural' is fatalistic.
It involves the belief that people
are powerless to change events.
Although no one can prevent
an earthquake,
there are ways people can reduce
the damage done - what Professor Easthope
calls additional harm.
Often, this additional harm,
things like the spread of diseases
or destroyed roads and buildings, are
worse than the disaster itself.
Fortunately, ways to limit
the damage are within our grasp.
If something is within your grasp, it is
very likely that you will achieve it.
It may be impossible
to stop disasters from happening,
but there are ways to limit
the number of deaths. An earthquake
in the middle of the ocean
is less of a disaster
than in a populated city.
So one technological solution
involves computers
mapping geological
movements to identify places at risk.
But low tech solutions can be
just as effective.
Bangladesh has seen a hundred-fold
decrease in cyclone deaths
since the introduction of
its new monitoring and alert system.
Ilan Kelman,
Professor of disasters and health at
UCL, has been involved in the project
and told BBC Radio Four's
Inside Science, how it worked.
What Bangladesh has done... has realised,
we cannot have
one hundred thousand people dying
in a cyclone each time.
So, in addition
to having people on bicycles
with megaphones going out and saying,
'look a cyclone is coming,
please get to shelter'. People in the
danger zones have grown up accepting
that their shelters will be safe,
knowing where the evacuation routes are,
but most importantly, that they
can return afterwards to their homes
and to their livelihoods because
they've built the infrastructure
and they've built their jobs in order
to avoid being destroyed by the cyclone.
One low-tech solution
involves people on bicycles
shouting warnings about
approaching cyclones into a megaphone,
a handheld cone-shaped device
that makes your voice louder
when you speak into it.
Once people know the danger,
they can start the evacuation –
moving people from a dangerous place
to somewhere safe.
The Bangladeshis have built shelters
which protect everyone:
children, the old and sick,
even animals,
so that when the cyclone is over,
they can safely return
to their livelihoods – their job
and other activities which give them
the things they need to live.
Well, it's great to see people working
together to survive cyclones.
Earlier, we were talking
about other natural disasters.
We were and I asked you
which disaster you thought caused
most deaths and you said you thought
maybe earthquakes which was... the right
answer, which is why these new ideas
to save lives are so hopeful.
OK, let's recap the vocabulary
we've learnt from this programme
on natural disasters.
Unpredictable events or catastrophes
which cannot be controlled by humans
and which are sometimes called
acts of God.
Fatalism is the belief that people
are powerless to change
the way things happen.
If something is within your grasp,
it is likely to be accomplished.
A megaphone is a handheld cone-shaped
device that makes your voice louder
when you speak into it so that
people can hear you from far away.
Evacuation means moving people
from a dangerous place
to somewhere safe.
And finally, livelihood is your job
or the work that gives you money
to buy the things you need to live.
Once again our six minutes are up.
Goodbye, everyone. Bye.